[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france 24 la
tasa de embarazo temprano en américa
latina y el caribe es la segunda más
alta a nivel mundial la pobreza la falta
de garantías de educación sexual y
también de ambientes amigables para
crecer libres de violencias y protegidas
son sólo algunos desencadenantes de este
fenómeno y las cifras empeoraron con la
pandemia lo que no es para nada una
sorpresa por más de un año hemos
registrado en este programa como las
restricciones del nuevo coronavirus han
resaltado aún más la vulnerabilidad de
nosotras las mujeres en estos casos de
embarazos y maternidades tempranas que
no provienen de un consentimiento
informado y que por lo tanto no son
planeadas ni deseadas las niñas y las
adolescentes se quedan sin opciones no
sólo están limitadas en sus
posibilidades de una crianza respetuosa
para sus hijos también se quedan sin
acceso a la educación digna y se
estancan en su desarrollo personal y
profesional perpetuando cadenas de
pobreza
la ong plan internacional advirtió que
mientras dure la pandemia los embarazos
de niñas y adolescentes seguirán en
aumento lo más preocupante es que la
propia crisis sanitaria impide tener
datos actualizados y medir la gravedad
de la situación aquí un resumen de lo
que sabemos
alrededor del 18 por ciento de los
nacimientos en américa latina'
corresponden a madres menores de 20 años
de edad lo dice el informe sobre
embarazo adolescente realizado en 2020
por el fondo de poblaciones de las
naciones unidas en argentina colombia
ecuador guatemala méxico y paraguay
el indicador es una pésima noticia para
las mujeres y para las comunidades con
las gestaciones tempranas se pierden
millas y millas en derechos humanos se
perpetúan la pobreza y la discriminación
por razones de género y la ong plan
internacional presente en 12 naciones
latinas advierte que en pandemia
retrocedimos en tres factores decisivos
en la lucha contra el embarazo temprano
acceso a los sistemas de salud acceso a
información sobre salud sexual y
reproductiva
acceso a servicios de asistencia deborah
cóbar directora ejecutiva del plan
internacional en las américas concluyó
que los riesgos que enfrentan las niñas
en la actualidad son mucho mayores en el
contexto de la pandemia debido a las
implicaciones que puede presentar un
embarazo implicaciones para la
supervivencia de las gestantes así como
para sus perspectivas de futuro de
acuerdo con la organización mundial de
la salud las complicaciones relacionadas
con el embarazo y el parto son la
principal causa de muerte de las niñas
de 15 a 19 años en todo el mundo y
cuando las madres sobreviven enfrentan
consecuencias en su bienestar mental
especialmente cuando sus maternidades
fueron fruto de la violencia sexual su
salud física estará comprometida a largo
plazo principalmente cuando tuvieron
gestación es antes de los 14 años en esa
etapa de la vida los embarazos son de
alto riesgo
anualmente más de 15 millones de
adolescentes se convierten en madres dos
tercios de ellas llegaron a esa
situación por falta de información para
prevenir embarazo o por violación
ante ellas está un panorama de falta de
cuidados en su entorno y de escaso apoyo
económico por lo que no pueden continuar
con su educación y son privadas de
oportunidades profesionales en el futuro
además plan internacional registra que
cuando logran incorporarse al mercado
laboral en la mayoría de casos trabajan
en la informalidad o en empleos
precarios y mal remunerados una
desigualdad que ellas no buscan pero que
deben enfrentar para sobrevivir y para
conversar de este tema está en ellas hoy
amalia alarcón beckelmann ella es
gerente regional de programas de
transformadores de género e influencia
en plan internacional
amalia bienvenida gracias por estar con
nosotros y en muchos casos los embarazos
tempranos terminan en nacimientos pero
también están estas gestaciones
interrumpidas espontáneamente o porque
una niña no tiene la estructura física
para aguantar un embarazo o porque se
realizan abortos sean legales o ilegales
en cualquier caso la muerte de una mujer
es una de las opciones después de las
gestaciones tempranas y en el mejor de
los casos
van a tener secuelas para toda su vida
hablemos de esto
y ante todo primero buenos días y
muchísimas gracias por el espacio
realmente valoramos este espacio porque
si coincidimos con que el embarazo en
niñas y el embarazo en adolescentes es
una problemática real y una problemática
que como bien han señalado ustedes está
afectando seriamente a la mitad de la
población de la región como bien decías
él hay que hacer como una distinción muy
clara de lo que es embarazos en niñas
menores de 14 años que sí o sí es
producto de una violencia sexual y un
embarazo en adolescentes que puede tener
múltiples causas como bien decían si
puede ser también causa de una violencia
pero también puede ser causa de falta de
acceso a métodos de planificación
familiar de falta de acceso de educación
integral en sexualidad y como bien
decías las consecuencias son graves van
efectivamente desde la muerte de estas
niñas por causa del embarazo como bien
decías una niña de 10 11 12 años su
cuerpo no está preparado para soportar
ese embarazo y si aguanta el embarazo
efectivamente las consecuencias físicas
y psicológicas para su futuro van muy
graves yo creo que todas todos hemos
visto en algún momento noticias porque
llegan a los medios y nos escandalizamos
cuando hay un caso de una niña de 11
años embarazada
normalmente el seguimiento y la atención
llega hasta el momento que da luz da luz
y como que nos olvidamos de ella
si uno hace seguimiento más a largo
plazo con esa niña se va a encontrar
efectivamente incluso hasta con intentos
de suicidio abandono escolar
discriminación de parte de su comunidad
no va a conseguir salir del ciclo de la
pobreza una niña ex embaraza de los 11
12 años y da a luz a los 11 12 años no
está preparada ni física ni mentalmente
y la sociedad tampoco está preparada
para acompañar a esas niñas y darles el
apoyo necesario entonces es fundamental
el trabajo de prevención y también la
trabajo de acompañamiento para que ellas
que efectivamente pues ya salieron
embarazadas y no podemos ignorarlas y
borrarlas del mapa
a preocuparnos sólo por el momento del
embarazo dio a luz ya sigue ya es madre
entonces ya no merece una atención como
niña que sigue siendo
más que un embarazo y una maternidad es
para toda la vida y por eso la
importancia de que las maternidades sean
deseadas sean planificadas y sobre todo
que lleguen en una etapa en la que ya no
estamos hablando de una niña sino de una
mujer consciente de lo que está pasando
en su vida y por eso quiero pasar a la
siguiente pregunta como amalia podemos
aspirar a tener mujeres sanas con mentes
funcionales libres si desde tan pequeñas
están y hemos estado todas expuestas al
peligro de abusos de violaciones de los
embarazos no deseados la educación
sexual ciertamente no es una prioridad
de los gobiernos eso se nota pero ellos
no ven las consecuencias más adelante en
nuestros sistemas de salud hablando de
salud mental y física de las mujeres de
esos niños que lograron nacer se pierden
millones y millones porque no
invirtieron en protegernos ni en
formarnos
efectivamente hay una de las
deficiencias que hemos visto es que
muchas de las estrategias de prevención
de embarazos adolescentes se centran
única y exclusivamente en la niña y sin
ver efectivamente como bien señalan la
responsabilidad de los estados y la
responsabilidad de la sociedad yo no
puedo como organización si tenemos un
montón de programas donde podemos
informar a las niñas sobre métodos de
planificación podemos informar y dar
educación integral en sexualidad pero
luego si esa niña vive en una comunidad
o en un entorno donde se le penaliza por
usar métodos de planificación familiar
vive en un entorno donde no se le van a
dar esos métodos de planificación
familiar de parte de los servicios de
salud el trabajo se hace a medias es un
trabajo es una responsabilidad de la
sociedad en su conjunto no solo de las
niñas muchas de las campañas que vemos
de prevención de embarazos vemos solo la
imagen de la niña y consideramos que
ella solita va a resolver su problema y
no es cierto mientras la sociedad en su
conjunto nos responsabilicemos
estamos haciendo el trabajo a medias
y por eso desde nuestros programas se
hacen muchos de trabajo con las
comunidades para que sea un esfuerzo
realmente de la comunidad que padres
madres cuidadores escuelas se involucren
en esta en esta tarea porque como bien
dices las consecuencias van mucho más
allá de las niñas yo me acuerdo una
frase que puede tener su su
contradicciones o por convicción o por
conveniencia si no lo haces por
convicción hazlo por conveniencia
ocurrencias los impactos económicos para
los estados son fuertes los gastos en
salud van a ser fuertes los lo que va a
dejar de ingresar el estado porque esos
niños no van a tener empleos formales el
día de mañana no van a pagar los mismos
impuestos que puedo pagar yo van a ser
fuertes entonces por un lado por otro
tenemos que convencernos que es una
responsabilidad de la sociedad en su
conjunto y ya nos vamos quedando sin
tiempo pero para que quede claro el
embarazo adolescente es violación a los
14 años puede haber un sentimiento
cuando es una relación sexual una
gestación una maternidad un tema
consentido para que no lo tengamos en
cuenta a todos porque estamos hablando
de niñas que ya no van a recuperar su
infancia y que están completas les
vulnerables creo que esta última
pregunta es realmente importante tenemos
que hacer una distinción clarísima en lo
que es embarazo adolescente y embarazo
en niñas todo embarazo por debajo de los
14 años es una violencia sexual si uno
mira incluso a nivel legal a la edad de
consentimiento sexual en la mayoría de
los códigos penales de nuestros países
es unos 14 15 años entonces ya desde ahí
es una relación que es considerada
violación sexual por debajo de los 14 sí
uno mire incluso los poquísimos datos
que tenemos sobre quiénes son los
progenitores en esos casos de embarazos
en menores de 14 años
gran mayoría de los casos no son padres
son hombres mucho más mayores que esas
niñas con lo cual desde ahí también hay
un abuso de poder por el factor edad no
solo por el factor género entonces si el
mensaje que queremos transmitir es claro
cualquier embarazo por debajo de los 14
años debe de ser considerado como una
violación sexual y debe de recibir la
atención que hay amerita no solo a nivel
sanitario pero también de acompañamiento
en todo lo que tiene que ver con acceso
a justicia para esos casos entonces si
hace falta estrategias específicas para
abordar embarazos por debajo de los 14
años que no es lo mismo que embarazos en
adolescentes donde también hay
situaciones de violencia pero pueden
influir otros factores que como bien
decíamos falta acceso a métodos de
planificación familiar falta de acceso a
la educación integral en sexualidad pero
si hay que hacer esa distinción entre
embarazos en niñas y embarazos en
adolescentes
mire yo le agradezco muchísimo por la
información y sobre todo por la
reflexión que nos hace a ver si podemos
abordar esta problemática de una manera
distinta gracias por estar con nosotros
y a nuestros televidentes solamente una
idea para pensar esta es la única región
del mundo con una tendencia ascendente
de embarazos en adolescentes menores de
15 años y se estima que cada año un 15
por ciento de todos los embarazos en la
región ocurren en adolescentes menores
de 20 años así que así llegamos al final
de ellas hoy sigan con nosotros y nos
vemos próximamente
[Música]